banks financial planners are filling us
in on the concepts of anchoring and
status quo bias
in financial decision making here's the
information
[Music]
so status quo bias is the tendency that
we have to resist
change even if that change might be good
for us
so for example you might have a real
estate agent or a cpa
who you've had for quite some time and
even though they're not meeting your
expectations
you tend to stick with them because
they're familiar to you and you just
don't want to switch
or maybe you're the type of person who
whenever you go out to eat
you order the same thing every time
because if you try something new
you may not like it and it's just not
worth the risk so in essence status quo
bias is
maintaining the status quo so status quo
bias affects our financial decision
making in a number of ways so for
example you might have a position
in your portfolio that you've had for
quite some time
and maybe it's time to move on and sell
it and buy something else but because
you've had it for so long
you're kind of attached to it so you
really don't want to sell it or for
example maybe you've inherited an asset
like a stock or a piece of property from
a deceased relative and
rather than sell it and use the cash to
buy something else
you hang on to it because again you're
attached to it i always tell clients to
ask yourself this
if i had this much money in cash today
would i use it
to buy that asset every day that you
don't sell an asset
is a day that you've decided to buy it
so the best way that i've seen to combat
this bias or any other bias for that
matter is just to have another set of
eyes in the room you know
as financial advisors it's not just
about what stocks should i buy or when
should i retire
but it's about putting somebody else on
your side and and giving a different
perspective to your situation to help
you make better decisions with your
money
anchoring is a behavioral bias that
marketers have used on consumers to
influence them for years
when studies have been done on anchoring
researchers showed that subjects were
exposed to a higher number first
they value that item at a higher price
point and vice versa
effectively you can be convinced to pay
more for something without even
realizing it if you've ever walked into
a store and you've seen a price tag that
says 59.99
and then a sale price underneath it for
39.99 that's drawn to anchor you to the
higher price point so the sales price
seems like it's a great value so many
clients out there have
made an investment that at some point in
time is worth less than they originally
paid
and so oftentimes they will want to get
out of that investment with the caveat
that returns to its original value first
this would be because they are anchored
to that original purchase price so this
bias may inhibit you from actually
investing something that would perform
better over the years while waiting for
it to return its original value which
actually may never happen
some clients have fond memories of the
good old days when there are much higher
interest rates in the economy
so it impacts the way they view today's
low interest rates counterintuitively
they now view mortgage rates which were
much higher back then as great values
today
whereas some younger clients may not
have that anchor in time where they may
have only ever known a low interest rate
environment
so likewise consumers today who don't
have that past anchor have a different
expectation of what a good interest rate
looks like
for more information go to
www.nsbank.com
wfs big thanks to nevada state bank for
being one of our community pride
partners it's appearing that home or